welcome back to another episode of
chappelle's world
and guess what we you thought i was
lying about us
they thought i was playing no
me
and white mike are running it
back
volume two we had more to talk about man
we you know what i was thinking about
that this week you know what it was you
know what it is it's because
the reason why i'm like able to run it
back with you is because we have such
thorough conversations about music in
general like out like like just at home
yeah the chris as roommates at the crib
yeah you know we start podcasting on the
couch yeah and just chill yeah you know
um so
i got some go ahead casey i have a
question do you guys uh get in fights as
roommates like dishes laundry [ __ ] like
that no no
i can't picture you guys ever being like
dude what the hell man i think we're
both pretty chill
energies anyway but also like we're kind
of we're never there i wouldn't say yeah
we're never there we're also like not i
feel like we're both the same type of
roommate whereas we're not disrespectful
space or anything like that
we're not yeah like it's just weird
because yeah we're never we're never
there i mean
we're there at the same time sometimes
but not all the time also the the place
where we live is nice it's roomy enough
where you know la sometimes you'll be
like living in a studio with a homie and
yeah you know
we gotta just on top of each other yeah
we have our space great space own
restrooms all that stuff yeah bro we
live but sometimes i'll be watching some
game or something like that and trying
to listen to this [ __ ] and hit this too
to be listening in the gym blossoms or
something
but what's dope is like where i'll be
listening to the gym blossoms at is i
have a door we have a door oh that's
what he's doing he could just close that
it closes this door and it really it
cuts off that sound you know you're
trying to move in i know right yeah
fascinated by the home dynamic oh yeah
yeah home dynamics yeah we're both on
the same page but also we're both
comedians and we're all we're both
adults we're both adults but also like
the fact that we're comedians like our
life is like you'll be out one weekend
i'll be on some weekends we're both not
even there for like four days yeah
um which is good if we're doing well
we're not at home yeah yeah
exactly thanks for answering back to you
scheduled programming yeah so i guess
i'm trying to think of where to start
because there's so [ __ ] many but i
have i have a list of things i want to
run with you okay okay because we've had
thorough conversations
i guess i'll start with an obscure one
that most people wouldn't know yeah but
if you know
you really [ __ ] know okay and that is
little brother i don't know i was just
gonna say that yeah where are you going
i actually just rolled up roommates i
was just rolling up and they uh i was
playing i played this old uh playlist
that i had on spotify that i probably
when spotify started i remember like
really diving into the playlist uh-huh
the first playlist i ever started is
called hip-hop by mjt if you need that
but it's hey hey we'll give it to this
honestly it's good it's like we'll put
the link in there's like it's like 32
hours um but it's just it's just good
hip-hop though yeah yeah and i was just
playing shuffle and little brother uh
the way you do it yeah
and it was uh that's the listening um
yeah little brother is a great
litmus test of
what you're hip-hop to start this off it
was two white guys that showed me little
brother you and then my my boss back
home in uh old boss at the hotel yeah
and uh he's a big little brother fan lb
business yeah white people understand
little brother so i it's interesting the
introduction to them though
it's funny too because also where we
left off last week or last episode which
you gotta check volume one come on now
um
was also like i think this point of like
really appreciating r b and their r b
turns into hip hop hip hop which is like
kind of what happened p diddy mixed them
all and then all of a sudden all the
samples yeah and all that [ __ ] and so at
that point i started discovering more
hip-hop and stuff and then it was
probably 0-304 though that was like deep
into high school when you got into
little brother i figured out who
i was really into underground [ __ ] yeah
and uh and little brothers like the
pinnacle of this is like the peak of
underground man you really found out
what black people were doing you know
what i was like what are you all doing
what are y'all doing and what is going
on hey i'm mike yeah i'm diving in
i'm mike i listen
that album was called the listening um
but also i remember stumbling across
them too with some homies we used to
dive deep on napster remember now yeah
and then it was kazaa you have kazaa and
then limewire
damn we did the same thing i want to say
it went kazaa first then napster
well i think napster was napster was big
and then it was like shut down
then it was nav shout out to metallica
yes yes
shout out to sean parker sean parker
shout out to justin timberlake in that
movie
um
shout out to that movie one honestly one
of the best movies of the last 20 years
you want to see a movie that moves also
shout out to trent resner for being the
soundtrack
for that movie yeah one of the greatest
soundtracks ever um
so
yeah it was it was that though it was
like that deep dive into kazaa and i
don't remember which one i remember
because i and limewire were the ones i
was using the most yeah cause lionwire
was like the [ __ ] limewire had a good
run because i because last time i
remember i was still using limewire in
like
2009.
it had a good run it probably was the
last one
and so you could get all these you could
do
you could really discover some stuff
and uh i i don't know if it was myself
or somebody else that stumbled across um
the track
off the listening the one where fonte
has a whole verse and he doesn't rhyme
yeah i can't even think of what the it's
um
track five uh so beautiful so fabulous
will you pull up the
little brother uh the listening
and uh track
yeah the tracklist checklist the
listening tracks
yeah
um oh the yo-yo goes hard whatever you
say
don't worry about it is this the one
that is this the one that's not on
spotify oh no they no it wasn't it
wasn't on spotify i think the listening
is on there oh yeah the no that was um
the get back
the thing that's like uh so unique and
like the big
backbone to little brother
is um ninth wonder ninth wonder yeah you
know which is like
super interesting
but also and not in that i'm not trying
to discredit you know
the flows of everybody you know big poo
and fun
fonte is in my top five he is and if
he's in anybody else's top five he's
he's probably five yeah yeah but he i
because i love him so much i love his
flow i love his approach towards
i don't know i love fonte yeah so i love
uh what's the one uh
tigolo fadolo tigolo for dolores i think
that was i think it was like one of the
first
tracks i heard where he was just by
himself yes and that track goes solo
yeah hard
hard he so the introduction of little
brother was really cool for me because
it also introduced me to ninth wonder
like you were saying yeah we were
talking about dilla he was influenced
heavily by dylan but what
what ninth wonder did was he used
something called fruity loops yes yeah
and so that was like a big thing in that
moment that nobody was using fruity
loops and it was something different
about i i wouldn't i'm speaking out of
turn and trying to say i know about like
the technical remember that you agree
but there was something with the samples
that he was doing that was way different
and he had great soul samples and all
that [ __ ] and so
the cool thing that ninth wonder
introduced me to is i was still not
crate digging really i was like cd
digging at this place called i moved
from best buy to everybody's records in
cincinnati ohio on montgomery road and
silver uh what was it called silverton
y'all have sam goody we did yeah i did
same goody at the mall yeah that was
good too yeah same good evening i got
this i got that diddy and mason biggie
song uh the remember singles uh-huh yeah
well you could just get a single that's
a big deal remember that and john used
to run that was that yeah and it might
have and then it was just like you had
that track and then you might add a
remix and then you had an instrument on
it yo but you just played that single i
remember singles
now people just drop it like differently
now like people like go drop like
you know because it used to be just yeah
just like a cassette tape that had like
maybe like a couple songs
and then like the way they would do it
it'd be the single
it'd be like a remix of the single yeah
and then like
the instrumental in another single and
then it might be a lucy too it might be
like something that they're like we
don't really like this track that much
but here it is yes
exactly and they'll throw that on the
tape or whatever but now though people
will just drop like an ep and then just
drop drugs drop like two
little two track eps sometimes yeah and
they won't even be on his side anywhere
else and i didn't i mean i didn't catch
that at first because i was like why
does it keep dropping like and these
aren't even on the record and it's like
oh it's just putting it's like just
putting content out there yeah
it's yeah and so
that was uh but then yeah so i went to
everybody's records
and i started doing that and what i
would do is i loved 9th wonder so much
so i would look for
other albums 9th wonder had produced
yeah so then i just started diving into
production
i was heavy on that too so you know how
to do your dives that's the way you got
to do it you got to
the thing that you're the thing that
you're interested in sonically
because i was like well i like the sound
of this yeah and so and you and i have
talked about this artist too that's how
i discovered sky zoo
so sky zoo is then another like really
underpriced so fontan's guys who are
like probably two of the more
underappreciated lyricists
in the in the last 20 some years and um
and so they made an album 9th wonder
made album called uh
the three-day theory or the three cloud
there or something like that but they
made this album in three days oh that's
wonderful zoom
and it's it was scott azuz it was uh
you know big first album now he's since
made
better albums that's a good introduction
to him and then
ninth wonder then also produced the
album with buckshot called chemistry
mm-hmm that's a beautiful this guy this
guy's
no he's crazy and then he's deep and
then he made
he made he also produced album called
monkey bars with sean price yeah and
then you showed me you also showed me
sean price yeah r.i.p sean
you want to listen to the craziest
lyricist he's from brownsville
and
he's so [ __ ] you know what dude just
google like uh sean pull up sean sean
price freestyles are like some of my
favorite things in the world because
it's so like i call sean price i call
brilliant ignorance
um yeah it's spelled
the s-e-a-m price
sean price
all right let's take a break from this
episode with my homie my best friend
white mike and talk about the best
kratom in the game right now happy hippo
i use created him to fire my brain
before any of my shows podcast or even
punk rock shows it's like a limitless
pill for me it's a best focused product
i think i've ever used uh best part it's
all natural okay so visit happyhippo
herbals.com and use promo code thickboy
for 20 off for life again that's
happyhippo herbals.com using promo code
dickboy for 20 off and that is for life
is uh he has since passed yes he has
passed and he
is good he's worth a deep dive but his
albums with
ninth wonder were monkey bars and
uh jesus the prize superstar
you showed me the you showed me the mike
tyson one mike tyson was dope that went
hard and it's called mike which is just
a dope name
like deep stuff that people don't
yeah i mean you just don't hear most
people talk about it i mean more people
should talk about more people actually
shout out to our
comedian pier uh andrew santino i just
saw yesterday yeah yeah on a podcast and
he had a shirt that said sean price is
right and it was a sh it was a priceless
right thing and i said he gets it i was
like santino gets it i was like that's a
dope shirt santino gets it and a lot of
people don't even know what that shirt
means they're like who that was sean
price
um worth a deep dive if you really like
lyrics and grimy bars yeah he had that
shirt
so okay so obviously the little brother
and that stuff was like early 2000s for
you that was oh three or three yeah so
then when did
when did
uh i'll move it to this way i guess when
did jay-z hit for you so then that was
so this he's a big jay-z so little
brothers on the back end of what i would
call my like underground phase of
hip-hop appreciation and i loved like
so it was probably and again i'll go
back to my brother the older brother
having cds laying around yeah i found
i'll never forget finding like jurassic
five quality control oh jurassic park
with jurassic park i don't think i knew
that oh yeah oh they're the early [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i don't know that yeah okay okay
and so quality control
uh captivate your body patrol yeah
what's that uh what was golden
golden was the third outfit the second
album uh ju was the first crew guess who
the j-u-r-a-s-i-c
well in the place of me yeah we don't
stop we got the riddle that makes it
right
yeah that's a crazy one that's a good
one i love those guys those guys all
together mark seven was one of my
favorite like i don't know there there
was some lyricists in there people like
charlie tuna a lot too yeah
because he just sounded different so i'd
like so i dove in underground i say this
to say like i was actually like
i didn't like jay-z for a long time
because i he was an underground he was
too shy he's two main streamers he was
like he's talking about money yeah and
girls uh-huh cars and i was like [ __ ]
that yeah yeah [ __ ] this guy ain't it
yeah jay-z is gonna [ __ ] you and i swear
to god i thought that for so long uh-huh
and i don't know what i don't know what
track it was
because god was going to say like he was
talking about all that all the stuff
that you're saying he was talking about
he switched it up
i don't even think he switched it up i
think it's the person it's not mature
mature yeah well definitely he
definitely matured but also like i don't
even i think it's just the outside
perspective of what jay-z was in that
era because again it's this diddy
influence era it's post biggie it is
it is like the late 90s early 2000s
there's this split in hip hop i always
thought because i also grew up
in cincinnati ohio so i love dj high
tech was like our dude so anything dj
had tech touch was it so we were into
ruckus records we were into talib we
were in the most deaf black star yeah
yeah reflection eternal uh those albums
like meant the world reflection eternal
those are class and those are classic
albums
but that was my
perspective on what real hip-hop was
supposed to sound like and honestly i'm
not wrong no you're not you're not wrong
at all like most deaf black on both
sides like all that [ __ ] and then i was
like oh this is what black people are
doing
most deaf talent wow
actually i might not be ready for this
[Laughter]
and so
that was my introduction of what hip-hop
was supposed to sound like and then i
was underground and then like atmosphere
was introduced to me and i was like this
is some of the best [ __ ] i've ever heard
yeah yeah you're [ __ ] you [ __ ] with
that people went people were like this
is my favorite white mc was eminem it's
like no atmosphere this huh so slug is
is that who you were is that who you
were
listening slug is mine
yes sluggish slug is my favorite wife
doesn't even ever listen to this yeah
100 yeah yeah so shout out to marshall
but uh yes slug from atmosphere is my
dude right and then i listened to
hieroglyphics and deltron and all that
[ __ ] so i was like deep into that and i
was like man [ __ ] jay-z [ __ ] all these
dudes like [ __ ] jay-z it was two yeah
and i was like man nah's got him on that
man i didn't even listen to takeover
and um
and it was blueprint two so whatever the
year that was i think that was oh two
route has uh
it had uh bonnie and clyde
yeah
oh
oh really it happened
it was a double disc actually which is
uh not a great look but um tough
nazi put out streets disciple and then
jay-z thought it'd be a good idea to put
the double album out it was the last of
the double album attempt yeah
and no nelly was the last sweatsuit yeah
come on
he was like what if i got tim mcgraw i
don't wanna [ __ ] track these
[ __ ] gonna blow them yeah
they're gonna blow their [ __ ] one of
the smartest marketing oh yeah hey he
marketed so well
he's like i'm a country boy
also
you can actually buy both those albums
individually too yeah which is
intelligent gosh that's so funny also
speaker box
oh yes
love below yeah but um
so it was blueprint two though
when i i'll never forget just diving
into it and i had a blue walkman
remember those sony walkman discs
and uh
i dove deep into those albums and it was
called the gift and the curse blueprint
too yup
and
it was the first time i realized i was
like oh
this dude's one of the most lyrical
because i was obsessed with lyrics i was
like man todd lib talk about real [ __ ]
commentary yeah yeah talk about real
we're talking about this yeah and then
you know there's a track on there jay-z
breaks down like this whole
this whole story there's this crazy
story i forget what track is called
that he talks about this kid's life and
how he grew up and how he didn't know
his father and all this thing and then
it comes back and it's a story about how
he ends up shooting his own father in a
stick up because it was like this is the
way that your life turned out because of
the choices that you made to deal with
it and all this stuff and i was like
holy chat
yeah
yeah and then like there's so many
lyrical things that he does and then
that was my thing that i would do at
that point that was when i realized i
had to go back listen to all of jay-z
yep i got reasonable doubt i got volume
one volume two volume three uh-huh i got
blueprint i did the unplugged album
and he's since been your favorite that's
your number one
and it and that is that's what i'm
saying about jason number one if jay-z
isn't number one on your list then
you're not listening enough really
haven't listened
do you strongly feel that way i don't
think it's i think it's actually a silly
argument to say
yeah anybody else's even i know it's
always weird when people try to argue
like best rapper alive like current i
don't know who's number two
like
the argument is numbers you're number
two my number two is weird because i
think it again and then your top five
gets real personal but that's what i'm
saying yeah it's personal my number two
is black thought from the roots oh yeah
and like again just listen just listen
crazy how lyrical he is especially his
10 minute freestyle i don't know if you
knew about that that's did a 10 minute
freestyle on funk flight yeah
so i like i like black thought okay
third
and then ooh it gets it gets funky i do
always have you i have to put biggie in
there just because i love biggie so much
yeah
this is all personal yeah and uh
biggie's my dude and then um
[ __ ]
and then i would put
i would put kendrick and then i'd
probably put like fonte and those are
like my five yeah yeah and that's what
zeke would say and then the thing is
dude catch me on a weird day i'll put
slug in there catch me on a weird output
royce the five nine in there oh yeah
that's a voice yeah that's another one
of yours yeah okay so
all right we're talking about jay-z
but there's something we always have
deep conversations about
what's that and that's kanye west
and i think you and i are like a lot on
the same page
in how we feel
about kanye west
and
i and and i've i've said this to you
before
but i and i've said it on this on this
podcast as well i think i said it when
david lucas was on but i
i feel
like he
is the closest thing to what like
michael like as far as big as michael
jackson
i'm talking about i'm talking about
music and like you know
like going out there and you know just
being this massive artist on a level to
where you're just so like in awe
by what he's doing up there his his
global impact is crazy yeah and
and uh it's yeah i agree completely i
think sonically
his influence on music is
uh
as big and as grand as michael jackson
and also he's probably you could argue
he might be more influential than
michael jackson only because
of the
the times that he lives in and the
influence that you can have on social
media so quickly true that's true that's
fair i
i don't know i have a the perspective i
always had on kanye not always but like
more recently is like
he might be the most
influential artist
of all time because of the time that he
lives in
okay because the fact that everybody you
know has an opinion on kanye west i
don't give a [ __ ] if you like it or not
yeah you have an opinion on him and he
emotes he creates an emotion within you
so like it doesn't matter if it's
positive or negative it's like you think
about kanye west so when he does
something it's news every time every
time and it's like and it could be the
the most smallest thing yeah
it could be his outfit dude when he's
going off on twitter
half of america knows it's happening
yeah if they don't within the next
couple days somebody's like bro you
didn't see that the other day here's the
thread it's all screenshotted
and uh and also he posts things and
deletes things and they're still exist
eternally because people screenshot it
yeah that's the most i like you guys
because i want to keep it because
they're like yo look at the [ __ ] his
instagram is one post but we we know all
of his posts because we know all of his
posts posted deletes it and it's
impactful yes and uh
and also what he's done that that's the
other crazy thing about him is
he's definitely our michael jackson
because of the way that michael jackson
rose to fame is something that will
never be duplicated again no because of
the times yeah there's yeah there's no
way that could [ __ ] cause a tv how it
worked you saw him on motown 25 and yeah
like it changed your life and you
remember where you were
kanye
it'll never happen again because think
about when kanye rose to fame oh three
was the first album right oh four or oh
four okay oh four was also the year that
twitter started
oh no oh four was i'm sorry that
facebook facebook started yes facebook
started
and then he rose to fame and by 08 he'd
taken over
music almost exactly right almost yeah
like he but i think what oh it was a
graduation
07 was graduation 08 was 808 mom died
around there and then eight awaits and
heartbreak was around then too yes
and 08 is twitter
so great and then yeah so like he hit
and then
so he's also the artist that rose to
fame and was at the height of
his power during this social media era
and
i think that that has to do with his
reach because
i don't know i mean obviously on every
social media platform you're talking
about what influences you and music is
the biggest thing that influences you so
it it is an interesting thing that his
rise came yeah and when i when i think
about kanye
you know to get the you know my personal
thing you know obviously yeah like you
know hear the first album [ __ ] blown
away
uh second album uh
[ __ ] late late registration blown
away but it was graduation that's the
one that a lot of that did it for me
yeah because it was a period of time in
my life other than barry bonds yeah it
was a period time in my life
where i realized
oh wait i i don't i don't live with my
family i didn't live with my i don't
live with my biological
and it didn't hit me and for some reason
it hit me with that album yeah and i
don't know why or what it did but i
think the song uh you know i wonder
just like did that to me yeah like it
just like opened up all these doors
but then the whole album like you know
from from top to bottom like champion
stronger i wonder like it and the way it
just goes it's a great hour and then uh
homecoming you know like chris martin
like the way that album goes like just
pulled every single feel out of me
damn i do a song with coldplay turn
around and jay got a song with coldplay
damn i'm like damn no way
translate espanol no way jose did it
didn't uh nick davis do that line on his
i don't know oh he's because nick nick
loves kanye that's it he i think he
rapped yeah it might have wrapped that
line i don't know is that because
jay got a song with coldplay i can't
remember called beach chair but like
that's what he did for me and then to
watch him like continue to grow i was
just like man this is it's kind of
undeniable well that's how i feel i i i
think that he is i said it last time you
asked me the my favorite artist of all
time i don't even think of him as a
rapper and i think it's disrespectful
and i think he's even said that anything
he's saying he's saying that
and i it's funny when he said that i was
like damn that's crazy because i've
actually had that conversation with
people i'm like yeah he's not a rapper
he's an artist and i also think it was
that time it was at that time that i had
realized
that our lives were about to change
cootie uh no kanye's life is changing
cootie your life is very much the same
uh
go back to chicago yeah
yeah
so
but yeah kanye is his his rise is
something that i always appreciate and
great artists too is
and this isn't only kanye but i think
all great artists throughout their
career
they
dive deeper within themselves and the
deeper that you can dive within yourself
i think about this a lot with stand-up
as well as
as your career goes on if you can
continue to dive deep within yourself
and look within yourself to create more
and figure out who you are more yeah
you're going to be able to continue to
create great art and also most times
better art yeah and you can look at that
from across the board [ __ ] elton john
billy joel like great artists in the
past billy joel [ __ ] and then you
look at kanye but i also think like
kendrick lamar does a great job of that
as his albums get deeper he gets deeper
within himself kendrick man that's yeah
that's one he's the one that that yeah
i know i like i i love kendrick and you
know what because i you know i had heard
like
songs you know and i i'd see i remember
at cinema concert
at the clubhouse in tempe i think you
were there too yeah we just didn't know
each other yeah we didn't know each
other you know it was crazy a school boy
opened up for him that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah now i love school uh-huh
and so uh
you know
i think when i saw him there at the
at that concert it was it literally we
saw kendrick in like a tiny
it was like 2011 and 2011. i think
there's probably 500 people there
no less anything less than that yeah
that doesn't fit 500. that place
probably fit like
200 million oh yeah you're right i guess
it was it was yeah because it was almost
like valley bar size yeah so small but
meanwhile what what what i took away
from that what was your takeaway his
performance was like as if it was an
arena that's what i thought like it felt
like it was just
big he was clear he clearly had bigger
visions bigger goals yeah and kanye had
that early obviously
in kanye
and he
first of all see the doc
the coolest thing in that documentary
the takeaway was like oh he had this
vision from the from jump from jump and
kendrick you could see being able to see
him that early he had that from jump too
because do you remember [ __ ] and patron
when he did that oh yeah he brought the
lead in he had a chair and he had like
tupac plans yes and then he uh he had
patrolling with him on stage yeah and he
was doing this whole like it was like
theatrical yep and it was like a one-man
show meanwhile this was in a room full
of 200 people and he went so he
committed so hard to it and i was like
what's he doing and then i was just like
if this [ __ ] plays yeah yeah
yeah because i love that song but it was
it wasn't until uh to pimp a butterfly
that really like hit me and then made me
go back and like really listen to his
[ __ ] and then when damn came out i was
like i think damn is like i think damn
is like a perfect album i think damn is
one of the you ever listen to album
casey that [ __ ] have you ever
listened to it backwards that's just
crazy you're the one that told me about
that i don't even know yeah but i would
say i have that on vinyl backwards oh
you do yeah
uh
but you're not kidding you
uh he so he released it so this is the
crazy thing about kendrick martin yeah
he released that album as like 12 tracks
and if you listen to it one way it's it
has a it's very uh deep it's yeah every
song is called like one word and it uh
it speaks about things it's huge themes
that he's covering in that and if you
listen to it one way it sounds one way
and you can listen to it all the way
back
and the dude that he had uh
dj was it kid capri was dude screaming
all over it
and i forget what he's screaming on it
but he's like uh he's talking about
death he's talking about
dying and yeah and and
all that type of stuff if you listen to
it backwards it's
a completely different message
but
arguably more an impactful message and
it's about your life going backwards
because that's crazy because you start
on damn if you start at the begi if you
start at the end it's actually the song
about him
and uh top dog is the the
tde ceo
and
if you listen to it backwards it's
actually the track
um what's it called duckworth and yeah
duckworth is a song that he talks about
his father and top dog
meeting
and interacting and not and him sticking
him up and not killing his father and
not shooting his father instead actually
realizing that he was potentially in the
wrong and them meeting and that
introduction was the reason that
kendrick ever met top dog and they
started tde together
and so but if you listen to it the other
way
then that's the last thing you hear
which is also very impactful too
isn't that crazy it's a nutty it's a
nutty album if you and that's what
that's what and then the second track
would be god and then yeah so
yeah i listen to it backwards the thing
i love about do it forwards and
backwards the thing i love about
kendrick is that
like
he's such an introvert
but like
makes the
like the loudest noise when he drops
something
when he when he puts something out i
like him and he's like him and frank
ocean dude like oh it's like they'll be
like they'll do nothing
and then they'll just like pop and
they'll just the biggest thing and it's
just like yeah he hasn't done anything
he hasn't dropped down since 2017. when
he dropped
black panther album too he did the black
oh yeah i forgot yeah but that was it
2018 but yeah but like as far as like
his you know studio
album as kendrick lamar 2017 was the
last time well he he he's the type of
cat that wouldn't tell you
i've met about that um have you yeah did
you meet kenny uh-huh what you it was it
was a tour you saw him on with travis
scott oh you saw me i met uh
yeah that's crazy yep you didn't
interact with some cool people because
of that yeah yeah because working at the
hotel oh bro i interacted with everybody
travis i like travis that i watched that
people loved me at the hotel i saw first
of all that was when i i didn't know
nothing about travis scott and i saw it
floating on that bird
golden eagle
and go to images
eagle
bro this [ __ ] was floating on it
where's it at
um right there yeah what's so funny
that's a whole toy so funny i told him i
said i didn't go to the concert last
night i was like but my homie was there
and he said he was flowing on the eagle
he goes yeah he's doing [ __ ]
he's playing goosebumps
i was so high i was like this
[ __ ] is crazy i had i never like
dove into him and then i i i honestly i
think he's like kanye like what's cool
is like he's got it cool it's like he
opened for
kendrick lamar
and you know and became trap and was
able to jump off that become travis
scott but meanwhile kendrick lamar had
opened for kanye and then yeah remember
that yeah i can't remember what tour
that was um was that what that would
have been it might have been jesus
yeah cause 2013 would have been jesus it
might have been jesus no it wasn't
nobody over him on life of pablo yeah
because he had a floating stage oh he
was just oh he opened with father
stretched my hands and you were like
oh [ __ ]
he's on that damn stage so i haven't
seen
in and i hate that i haven't
but the the one and only time that i saw
kanye live was the late registration
album oh that's probably a good one the
the yeah his second album uh the touch
the sky tour and let me tell you
like
saying what you're saying this now
yeah saying what you're saying now about
like his performance i felt that same
energy yeah and that was what 2005
and so yeah that's how [ __ ] powerful
and like the second tour yeah and i
think how much like he understood
himself and believed in himself and just
watching him like really just double
down and kanye
the coolest thing about kanye to me is
the fact that he doesn't just make a
song thinking about how it might sound
to the audience on an album or something
he also makes whole albums thinking
about how they might present in a tour
yeah like i'm like that his vision of
like the whole thing is nutty to me like
the life of pablo
is
uh such a [ __ ] good album but also
the fact that he knew that he would take
it to arenas in the way that he did
when you go back in that album you're
like oh he knew
exactly what he was trying to do with
this album because that album when you
listen to it you're like this should be
played in an arena this album should be
and he and then the introduction to that
album was at madison square garden in an
arena an arena and it just is such a
crazy album that it
it has that famous song with rihanna
yeah like the song chris brown the
production on it is it it's so crazy you
want to know one of my favorite things
that he's done
is what he did
on all the lights
as far as utilizing uh with all the
sounds the voices the you know how many
features
are on all the lights
right elton john's on it ellen john's on
it yeah
go to let's go to all of the lights i
need to look this up it's like because i
can't remember i mean
fergie
look up uh just type in kanye west all
the lights all the lights go maybe go to
the yeah
vocals yeah yeah because charlie wilson
from the gap band i think is on it as
well
yes so many also somebody nobody's used
charlie wilson better than the dream
also nobody used to dream nobody's used
the dream's voice better than him oh my
gosh so drake alicia keys is on there
yeah
he used so many people on there so and
then at the end he's combining all their
voices to make it sound like
ryan leslie ryan leslie remember ryan
leslie yeah who could what tony williams
i don't even know tony williams he
sounds cool who's tony williams oh you
know tone
and emotionally
rihanna
and john legend and he combined all of
their votes
and that's all on that one track and you
can't tell
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy
that's that album i know
don't do it that's that's like a perfect
album that's a perfect album i will say
my favorite album my favorite kanye
album as you know is
jesus oh yeah you love jesus i don't
know why i just i didn't like it
he worked with register on that no so he
actually the
i don't know if kanye's ever even like
really admitted to it but it's pretty
known that he was working with this guy
named saul williams saul would say who
has worked with who worked really hard
deeply with trent rashford he is
somebody that has an album called um
it's called if you don't know saul
williams look up sallway yeah i can't
even i don't even like saying that the
title of the album but it's called niggy
tardus
[Laughter]
it is an amazing album yeah it also is
like largely if you go listen to that
album people say that kanye actually
stole the sound
of that album for yeezes and it is it's
very stripped down i need to listen to
it it's yeah i think i've tried it you
should you would actually really like it
it's a very good album yeah um
and
saw williams and him actually worked
together on a couple songs so he
definitely was aware of saul williams
style and all that [ __ ] uh-huh and um he
kind of took a a large influence but
that was that was that useless album was
an album that wasn't well received at
first
no it was so aggressive so aggressive
meanwhile people go back to it and like
yeah i [ __ ] with this album
it's so good and yeah so i don't even
know if it's ahead of its time as much
of it's just like it's almost like this
is what happened and then yeezus and
then it's like all right let's go around
you know this album it's the one that's
got the one where him and kim were on
the motorcycle and she was naked yeah it
was bound on that you don't know about
that it has
blood on the leaves you if somebody told
me blood on the leaves is their favorite
kanye song they're not wrong they're not
wrong that's one of the most like
i don't know that song goes through it
and that's that that's the song that
actually he talks about chris humphries
and and kim oh yeah and he's like uh i
remember christmas now you're sitting
court side wifey on the other side
separated i caught that apartheid
that's something that your heart does
and that's crazy and then he does a
whole c murder thing with uh
uh my god
that's that's crazy
there's some new orleans [ __ ] in there
all right [ __ ] but that album to me
is beautiful and i think also people
might not have [ __ ] with kids the
first track is something kanye prides
himself in they're not kind of on site
but everybody everybody's so
the introduction his albums are so great
like good morning good morning um
what's uh
what's the one on his first album with
uh
there's drugs dylan
like his first his first track
oftentimes it's so like a beautiful
introduction to the album and he's this
is the first one on the jesus is like so
aggressive what's the first one on uh
late registration yeah what's the first
one isn't it the one with uh
it's not good i heard him say it heard
him say we heard him say
his name adam levine adam levine yeah
and i heard him saying yeah oh my god
it's like all it's always a very nice
like hey let's maybe lube lube up your
ears on these yes and then and then
jesus is like what if we [ __ ] uh
anally with no vaseline
it was like how about if we just dove
right
no spit
and uh
and that and so for your eardrums that's
an aggressive album
an aggressive album but it's good for
long drives it's a great album and that
album then the production style on that
if you if you listen to the era of which
he he transitioned from that and then he
went straight into uh watch the throne
and that is very like experimental beats
but
that album
is crazy crazy now we're talking about
both the people we talk about jay and
kanye
and that album to me is like
it's also great for long drives because
it just goes it moves it's very it's got
some aggressive songs to keep you up
um
but that's like that's one of those duo
yeah that's the thing about kanye he's
he's really good at making
from start to finish albums that you
just go
damn i love that album
from start to finish the best thing
about kanye i think is a lot like
tarantino in the way where you can have
whole conversations about what's your
favorite tarantino movie what's your
favorite kanye album okay and honestly
no you're not wrong you're not wrong
nobody's wrong yeah uh it actually says
more about you than it does about the
artist that you're talking about
whatever your answer is says more about
like the fact that i like yeezy says
more about my preference of sound
than it does about it so let me ask this
is there an album that you could
not do without that that that i could of
kanye like that i need for sure no that
you could just like dismiss yeah um dude
honestly the weirdest [ __ ] is
it's [ __ ] up to say it but i don't
love his when i listen to his whole [ __ ]
i'm like i can get away with
drop the early stuff i actually like
late kanye i like more recent kanye i
like i like yeezus i like life of pablo
um i love
yay honestly
i like i love donda
uh yeah so i really think uh
i prefer all that stuff as far as what i
listen to of kanye i don't go back and
listen you don't go back so how about
with jay-z
if i could do without an album i know i
think i know what it is i don't know i
know what it is
it was the single
uh
but also and then i'm thinking about it
more also probably uh holy grail is
probably the one holy grail
but run this town goes hard when this
town goes hard doa actually i really
like thank you i love on that album um
um on to the next one with swiss people
also the next one yeah
like it's crazy that that j cole feature
is kind of wasted right the i think the
uh drake feature is kind of wasted the
drake features ways drake's talked about
that he's like we've got a couple songs
that we didn't hit on yeah that that's
the song off that yeah because it i
don't know yeah that could have been
that's also just a drake hook he didn't
actually rap on it which is weird yeah
it's just a drake hook reel as it gets
with jeezy it's kind of a messy album
but also drake wasn't who he was when
he did this so this is what i think hope
was just like kind of
yeah this is like hey get on this yeah
because i [ __ ] with you
um but my favorite check out that is
already home i was like young forever
also a lot
oh yeah yeah that's a good one that was
dope and then holy grail it's like
whatever but um
yeah but for the most part i need all
that j stuff oh i can also do all
without all the problematic r kelly uh
albums that he had
he definitely made like four albums with
our kelly
uh
and there's some [ __ ] on there dude
let fiesta come on right now the remakes
yo left fiesta come on come on now come
on it's a problem i forgot about the the
people forget yeah it's called like the
best of both worlds is that what it's
called they had like three hours the
best of both worlds
he really he tied himself he actually
has somehow like avoided avoided yeah
people don't even talk about it
dude there's like [ __ ] three albums
that's like volume one dude i'm telling
you
they're yeah look
uh go to wikipedia there's like
i swear right he says
he has to come on
they made they never made two more
what's the other oh yeah the unfinished
business it's like you should have
finished that business
[Laughter]
you should have those just been it was
pretty finished it was wrapped up it was
wrapped up yeah they didn't even finish
the tour
oh no they got no they got a very heated
fight yeah the tour guide i guess hove
and they're very they're both like
raised
from brooklyn raised in chicago
chicago [ __ ] so they they weren't having
that tour they made some money though
but
yeah those albums i can do with that we
don't talk about those yeah um
but hov i mean but if you want to just
and sometimes
people don't know where to start with
jay-z yeah i always think like the black
album to me is like the pinnacle of his
lyricism the pinnacle of his production
choice and stuff like that
the pinnacle of his like production
choice and stuff like that yeah and the
pinnacle of his lyrics are on the black
album to me and it was supposed to be
when we were tired but yeah i think uh
and then reasonable doubt you're saying
that's where people should start
it's a it's great yeah yeah you should
start with black album you could all you
could start with reasonable doubt but
like no it's too there's something about
with with him like i i agree with you
more on starting with black album than
reasonable doubt yeah because
once you
i feel like you hear the black album and
you go back you have this i feel like
you if you started with reasonable doubt
you already have this appreciation but
if you start with
black album then go to reasonable doubt
it'll elevate that appreciation because
also black um he's like a polished
project exactly because that was to go
back to like my love for hip-hop and how
i started discovering artists
that's when i started really diving into
artists what i did was i i usually found
the finished product like yeah my
introduction to ghostface wasn't uh
supreme clientele
it was a pretty tony album
yeah but like his solo stuff mine was
supreme client and that's the way that
should have been it for me but i did
that and i went backwards i would i got
like outcast i was obsessed with like
stankonia but then i went backwards you
know and i discovered all that early
[ __ ] and then
um who else did i do that with mass to
ace i remember listening to
one long hot summer
my old boss nate shout out to nate
sporbert back home in arizona he would
appreciate
th like he's going to appreciate this
episode it's stephen he's going to
appreciate this episode also shout out
to wu tank shout out to the bengals
shout out to the video baby
um shout out to drew sinclair shout out
to the [ __ ] white mike coming through
again you know i know they're
right you're going to be yeah you're
you're chappelle's world regular well
come on no one's ever been able to do we
should do deep dives on albums yeah we
could do artists we could break down we
could break down all kanye's [ __ ] in a
methodology gosh in a [ __ ] you know
hov ghost
you're maybe you're my deep dive segment
wu-tang you want to do tango let's do it
let's do a playlist to close it out
uh this is a lot
we didn't even also you know what's
crazy we didn't even do pop punk again
we didn't do pop or j-may we'll get it
watched we'll get it shout out to brand
new shout outs
i'll start off with uh
you know since we talked about i'll i'll
do tigolo for dolo yes that's a great
one that's a good
he can't spell he can't spell it
tiggelo
dolo i think it's t it's t-i-g-a-l-l-o
yeah
t-i-g-a
yep that is it for dolo for dolo and
then it's by fonte though and dolos
bro come on now
and then fonte is uh p-h-o-n-t-e
um
and then i'll stay with little brother i
think i referenced it
uh whatever you say is a really nice if
you don't know a lot about little
brother
the third verse by fonte
he spits it and he doesn't rhyme one
word one word
that's art that'll [ __ ] your whole [ __ ]
up i'll do jay-z
already home
i know we talk [ __ ] about blueprint
three but i was like i gotta give her
all right that's fair i'll give a
i love that you're already home i mean
already um and then i'll do
um
kanye blood on the leaves blowing all
the leaves that's gonna be such a crazy
transition from already home to blood on
the land um
[ __ ] who else do we [ __ ] talk about
um who do we we talked about ninth when
we talked about i'll i know what i'm
gonna do next
go
i'll do you get one
uh
[ __ ] if you're ready go
yeah if you're ready so do uh sean price
um
oh what's the what's the song called
though
hell
um
do sean
price um
there's a sky zoo track you showed me
that i really really liked
woo
so many good ones
oh my lord i know do uh do sean price
like you
hmm
that's too much i'll do um
i'll do uh
[Music]
i'll do skyzoo bed styles burning how
are you supposed to be uh that's like
like the two words yeah
just combined right
bed sty is bed
dash
sty st st ui
is burning
and then we gotta go yeah damn um
oh and then i did i know i'm gonna go i
know i'm gonna go and then didn't i
reference um oh yeah to to go back to my
roots in cincinnati you gotta go
um
reflection eternal yep
um
which one though
shout out to high tech i know right
ooh
i know what i'm gonna do all right i
know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna do
i know what i'm gonna i know what i'm
gonna do i'll do i'll do high tech
and i'll i'll do keep it moving
oh yeah that's a great one to go that
way and then do go reflection eternal do
blast
that's some cincinnati all right and
then
oh i'll go uh jurassic five oh yeah j u
it's the j you oh
j j a y
oh you
no no it's together
yeah
and then we also talked about
black dot
so if you want to hear
bars yeah
real bars
called um
oh my god what is it called
boom oh no do do web
isn't it web yeah it's wet
no i'm sorry it would be the roots
yeah the roots and the songs called web
how many we got there 10.
is that 10
that's hot that's a lot of bars on there
i know there's a lot of these [ __ ]
i mean and also if you could throw
atmosphere on there yeah they don't yeah
throw them on and god loves ugly
don't want it we do that we cool with
that because that's
that's what i love
damn all right white mike hey we did it
right we did it we did it again
deep dives with this one this is a good
one this is a really good one we're
ready for that y'all weren't ready you
weren't ready for that one you weren't
ready for that mm-hmm it's your meatball
ass so come on now i know i appreciate
it shout out to white mike um so my next
tour dates
uh i'll be
with actually with white mike yes
together san diego um san diego he'll be
featuring for me may 6th and 7th
new comedy club out there called mic
drop comedy club then i'm doing a
one-nighter in the hometown of phoenix
may 12th at uh stand up live uh then
i'll be uh i didn't put these on on
there but april 20th through the 23rd
i'll be in austin texas at the
moon tower comedy festival just doing a
bunch of shows around the city uh that
weekend then um
then
later in the summer i'll be
june 24th to 25th i'll be in east
providence rhode island at the comedy
connection and then follow mike at
turner comedy turner comedy he just had
a video drop on youtube
uh if you want to see his stuff uh
on don't tell comedy yeah
let's find out exactly what they should
type in so they don't know exactly where
to put michael turner
michael turner
don't tell yeah yeah put michael turner
comedy and it'll pop up oh it's the
first video that pops up so yeah just
put comedy because i'm not the running
back from the atlanta falcons yeah yeah
so yeah those are good highlights though
no i got tree trunks for thighs but not
like yeah support everything that white
mike does on the show at turner comedy
on ig all right perfect all right thank
you